meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wie projekt wissen hat man als youtuber
die möglichkeit so ein bisschen in seine
eigenen kanal rai zuschauern also zu
gucken was passiert wenn ich wie es so
dass hier die leute welche werden gleich
welche nicht und da ist mir das
aufgefallen und zwar es ist so fachleute
ich habe vor über einem jahr ein video
gemacht youtuber strichmännchen erwarten
mit luca und dieses video hat in den
letzten 28 tagen hunderttausend aufrufe
gemacht das sei das passiert halt nie
also jetzt kommt normalerweise online
dass youtube und kriegen dann ihre
klicks und sind verschwunden
das video ist ein jahr alt nach einem
jahr denkt sich youtube und steckte so
vor und war der monat haus aufrufe muss
los wurde aber da wir uns gedacht
scheinbar gibt da draußen viele leute
die gerne youtuber strichmännchen gucken
im moment und deswegen haben wir zwei
videos gemacht wird über strichmännchen
einmal dass hier auf einem kanal oder
aber das hat max kanal und ich würde
sagen wir legen direkt los youtuber
strichmännchen funktioniert wie normale
strichmännchen und mit youtube als man
alles klar da habe ich das erste wort
für dich in meinem kopf mental
hinterlegten gefangen an ich sage als
allererstes erste der erste schreck du
warst weil das ist so gemein dass wir
gesagt das ist alles klar
das ist einfach 6a leichter tnb
also ja was ist handelt sich dabei
natürlich um ein trabant ich hasse dein
leben hast du die möglichkeit einer
übernahme erst mal gesagt aber dann
fachgerecht erwarten hier gesagt er sagt
was also fange jetzt an mit der dazu so
leute
[Gelächter]
der youtube zeitversatz das ist mein
okay was ist das das feld oder gar das
medius gehört dazu vier jetzt mit vier
buchstaben
diesen spitznamen oder der wirkliche
kanal damit jetzt nicht verraten
spitze aber das muss man ja auch okay
was okay es gibt ja sozusagen einen
ersten buchstaben mit
ich besorgte so ein scheiß war so klar
also aber schon mal feiert man nicht
immer ich sagen ist schon mal falsch
das hat die sache ich habe schon gedacht
dass ein kurzer name ist das locker sind
auch wirklich bullshit musste 26
schon falsch habt ihr keinen bock drauf
wer weiß das ist mein kopf hängen die
biester ja also nicht als mal ich
verrate habe er die waffe war die sache
okay weiß was wir bei meinem ersten
youtuber sowie ihre genommen ich schaue
jetzt in die trends weiter und suchen
wir den spirit im längsten namen den 2
[Musik]
der war nicht dabei
ja
[Musik]
manchmal ein schlechter werden weil das
nächste was du sagst falsch wsk das
heißt also ich muss sagen dass mit
trends war wohlstands genommen naja ich
einen versuchen versucht der nächste
falsch ist denn du weißt nicht man ist
ja ein paar leute hier ich sage ich geb
dir einen letzten tipp mit ok also die
buchstaben zuvor schauen wir sind jetzt
nicht nur allen buchstaben mehr gut dann
logischerweise diese nicht kraft selten
aber selten da so viel wie ich nur
gesagt habe p
das ok ist nicht drin jetzt sagt was ich
mache mal nach unna alte hengst und die
hexe die übrigen kenne also ich habe ja
[Musik]
das kann youtube ist eine unternehmens
ist konnte das zelt nicht endgültig
zählt
das erste geld ein scheiß hier der ist
es was der zweck dass man jammert sie
sich die haare fährt ganz kurz mal
wiederholen wenn die sache selber
vernünftig
doch vorsicht wer das war lange jahre
hat sich gerade in werden immer mein
zimmer geschlichen und schläft hier auf
der couch leute ich bin mir da jetzt
überlegt ja was genauso meines perfekt
losgeht
wir sind besoffen nick macht weil die
schritte so schräg nach oben gehen
deswegen einmal eine perspektive april
bleiben sagte joachim janotta und
[Musik]
behinderte sich das ja ganz klar auch
bei von das ist ein klarer fall von s
[Musik]
b da ist dann ein gespräch über auch ich
habe 45 ungefähr 50 in dem ort onna
skandal vor asg kommen also eine app ist
es nicht nein es ist nicht ihr gut ihr
was griff geraten
hier wird etwas nicht gibt als jemand
der sagt jetzt müsst ihr ein schreiben
des harry potter brille so das fazit
bitte die kammer des schreckens öffnet
das macht
[Musik]
da sehe ich das wirklich and drin
also ja mach jetzt das könnte sie
möglicherweise sein dass er gefragt die
youtuber casey nein danke dann machen
wir das paar kleine parzelle ist da
läuft bei mir alter ich habe max kanal
und die beschreibung verlinkt passende
tv-team gerne abonniert und war durch
die scheiße von dir heute betrieben noch
ein für euch verursachen das video ab
und wird bis zur nächsten